should i talk about the end of
photography
are we about to do this now i'm like am
i gonna
am i really gonna bring this up but it's
up to you bro okay
so i guess i've never i've never talked
about this but
we've we've obviously gotten a lot of
comments about portugal on this podcast
on this podcast and uh it was we i don't
think anyone's really publicly talked
about it and
to preface this still love still love
everyone on the podcast i'm not about to
talk mad [ __ ] or anything like that
and the long in the story the long and
the short of it is that
we came into some creative differences
about
which way the podcast could go because
to me
potaku was the defining podcast of the
anichi
community as as i have just said and i
really wanted to push that further i
wanted to
i wanted it to i wanted potaka to like
evolve more yeah
yeah because i saw the potential in how
big the podcast could be because um the
problem was that
we had trouble keeping up with our
schedule and then we took like a
seven month break or something like that
it was very long i think it was it was a
very long
long day yeah yeah yeah and the reason
for that was
basically the podcast didn't really have
a like a designated leader right leading
in
so i've been like at the beginning of
the podcast it was mainly
me and tristan who were getting things
like getting getting things done
chasing up yeah i mean jean loved jean
she was she was like the mother of the
group but she was like she would like
come in and out
because she was very busy with her real
life holden [ __ ] talented as
[ __ ] talented guy but it was you know
i i know i've told this told him before
you know it's it's
unless you unless you tell if you tell
holden to do something he'll [ __ ] do
it
if you don't he won't do it if if you
don't he's not the type of he wasn't the
type of person
that would like push people to do it you
know and you know i think he's changed
now for the better and i think potaka
was definitely a big learning experience
for him as well so i think
he's definitely grown as a person but
back then it was mainly
it was mainly me and tristan who was
pushing stuff to get done on the podcast
and
tristan started to get less and less
involved because
he started to transition doing anime
reviews
as a hobby to actually finally getting
paid for it because he just
he had opened his patreon he was the
only one that was actively doing vid
videos companies that was at the time
when tristan was like really at his peak
yeah yeah he was like really growing at
that time exactly i remember this
patreon was a big deal
yeah yeah yeah exactly because he was
the only one who was
who had other commitments for his own
youtube channel so he just had less time
than all of us
and then for me that was also the time
when i got my job at the bbc
right right so you saw you see all these
factors coming into play where
the driving force of the podcast just
had
less time to really make episodes and
people in jaitarki we were all good
friends but
they were you know they weren't the
original four they were they weren't the
og4 they didn't really have
the i'd say authority to really take
over yeah
you can't really step in and be like
this is mine yeah yeah yeah exactly
so we basically took a seven seven month
hiatus or it's it's it's a haters but it
was more of not nothing was getting done
yeah i won't said anything in the group
nothing was really happening
they left you unread
and it was basically because we just
didn't have the time and
what what was the driving force for it
to be revamped was i that was the point
when i
wanted to return to youtube i was
getting bored of my job
and i was like okay first step i want to
put all my hard work into potaku
and really revamping this because
tristan's doing really well
with whatever he's doing with his
patreon and i
saw potential for not only me coming
back but also pushing poor taku into
something even bigger and better
than what it was yeah um with help
formerly you know trying to monetize it
and
they just basically making it have an
incentive for everyone to turn up every
week exactly
exactly and so it ended up being i was
the
big driving force to getting potaki back
on his feet and that's why i got
super super invested in it because i was
the one who was
getting trying to get episodes done i
was editing a lot of them
not because i wanted to be paid or
anything but i just wanted
this to you what you wanted your passion
i wanted i wanted my passion to be back
on the ground
yeah uh and as
as soon as i felt it was kind of getting
back off the ground
i remember tristan coming coming to me
and he was like i
i want it to end you know what i mean
right yeah and
um i looking back now i totally
understand why he did
right because this this is where this is
where i i put it back to creative
differences
because he saw that we weren't getting
as many views as we used to before the
hiatus
right and also the dynamic of the group
was
very different than when than when we
started
you know some people weren't getting
along as well as as
as uh as they were they were at the
beginning
so he wanted potaku to just
end there you know yeah yeah he he
wanted to be like okay instead of just
fizzling
fizzling out um i wanted to end here and
i really really tried to convince him to
be like
look i know we're going through some
very big issues now
but i see potential in this yeah there
was there was a lot of there was a lot
of factors
that i saw that could potentially have
driven a lot of hype back into potaku
um before we ended there we had um jean
had just left
yeah right but she was she was gonna
come back we had scheduled that
we had also scheduled mintaku too which
is the hentai episode
which was like our most um popular one
right so i was like look
it's we can do it we can do the comeback
plea i like i i
i really really tried to convince him
that
it was too early to end yeah because i i
totally agree with all the problems that
the podcast had
if in order to survive and to go further
we would have had to
make a lot of big changes and they could
have very easily blown up in our face
i guess it's one of those things where
it's like you could try but you could
very easily fail so it's one of those
things where you're like do i want to
put in this work and i can get the
guaranteed paycheck yeah why i really
did it right like i kind of get it but
at the same time i i'm like
as a viewer i knew how like big it could
have been as well looking in my position
now and i understand how it all works
like
yeah it could have been i think it could
have been something yeah yeah definitely
it would have needed a lot of work and
it
would have take we would have taken a
big risk and we could have failed
massively but for me as a person i would
rather
give that a go right right right one
down yeah then then wonder
and it got to the point when it was just
it was just like
it was just this one clash right of just
i wanted i
i thought it was too early to end it and
tristan wanted to
wanted to end it yeah and it was it was
unfortunate
that you know you know i i i say
unfortunately i didn't i didn't get my
way
he didn't listen to me i tried i
tried so hard there was a video that you
guys all made when it ended right and i
remember watching this and it was like
one of those moments you're like please
say psych yeah
please please say sorry jk lol but i
remember watching that video and it like
because
i remember the order was like you first
and it was like tristan was last
yeah yeah and i i tristan i love tristan
by the way just saying like but i
remember watching and i think like
man it kind of seems like everyone was
like really wanting to keep doing this
but then tristan didn't
almost as a viewer it wasn't like that
it was
at the end as a viewer i think that's
the impression yeah it could be totally
wrong just an impression i mean there
was definitely a faction that supported
my stance right there was the faction
that supported tristan's stance
i mean look like as someone who creates
now i can understand both
yeah i don't care about either i mean
it's definitely a tough decision right
now oh yeah
anybody in that position would have been
like ah [ __ ] do i take the rare score at
the end of the day if his heart's not in
it his heart's not in it right yeah
exactly
if you're going to like drag someone
along he doesn't want to do it yeah you
can't like
so was there no option to just do it
without tristan
i mean we we we wanted to respect
tristan's wishes because
you know we there was there was the
conversation of like
um should we do this without tristan you
know but
it just it just felt wrong yeah just
understand
because i i wanted to leave the option i
asked tristan would it be okay
if we continued and then you know
at any point if forever for whatever
whatever reason you want to return the
doors are
always open yeah and tristan was like
adamant no i don't
and i understand because this was his
baby
no i don't feel comfortable letting my
baby go and just
seeing what happens yeah so that's that
that's kind of that that was kind of
like the the last draw you know
there was no there was no going back
from that and yeah that's
basically how it ended and it was after
that
that um i i kind of lost a lot of
motivation because i put
so much of myself into getting this
revamped
and it just felt like it was just all
taken away and it was out of my control
and it i learned a lot from potaku with
like
learning working on group projects and
everything like that and i should
probably
and i want to say i'm not throwing shade
at tristan at all we still get along
great
yeah we all get electricity yeah yeah i
i i love tristan
it was just it was just a point where we
just had creative differences it happens
man it happens
that that that's i feel that's a very
normal thing people
i've what i'm trying to say is i've
really got to demonize and like don't
yeah yeah yeah i'm not demonizing
tristan i
like we just had a different way of
approaching things i you know i still
think back to potaku and i still think
hey i think it ended too early and he
obviously thinks the other way and he
thought the other way back then and
that's
basically what it boils down to how it
is man yeah that's how it is yes
obviously we don't want anyone going and
being like what the [ __ ] man why don't
you why don't you not believe in it man
i mean like
like like said earlier like your heart's
on it your heart's not in it right yeah
it's not gonna happen
i mean can anyone like really blame
tristan like again
it's it's a [ __ ] like i would have
really been liberating as well right
if i didn't believe in it i'm normally
someone who's like adamant about [ __ ]
right so i would be like no
no yeah i don't believe in this yeah
like i would be like that
yeah exactly so it's you know it's just
how it is right yeah
yeah and i mean yeah i mean i always
look back to think you know well what
could what could it be
what could be but that was that was just
the end of an era
and now we're in a new era and i'm you
know everyone's gone down the different
paths i
i'm really amazed to see what people are
getting onto nowadays and it's [ __ ]
great and i'm still
i you know i still speak to all the cast
members every now and again
especially when we get to meet at
conventions hey bottom line is that at
least there isn't a single member of
pawtucket that went and killed their
family
well that's a taker
yeah joey didn't kill his family
jesus christ oh my god
that's a [ __ ] tape oh my god okay